Hey bro, they're here, right?
Yeah, I just can't afford groceries anymore,
but it's fine. I've really gotten into dumpster diving lately.
It's really been an adventure.
Wait, seriously?
You can't afford food? Well, yeah,
prices have gone up cause of tariffs and deporting immigrants,
but it's all part of making America great again.
You mean the same America where billionaires got huge tax cuts
and now you're out here struggling to eat?
Well, billionaires investing more will eventually help us.
Trickle down economics. Bro,
you're literally eating out of a dumpster.
Hey, I'm just doing my part, okay?
What about your job?
You got laid off because the company outsourced everything.
Yeah, but I'm learning new skills.
Like foraging. You're eating out of dumpsters
and literally picking berries to survive.
Exactly. Living off the land,
just like our ancestors intended.
And you're still voting for Trump?
Well, of course.
Who else is gonna save this country?